the excitement among space enthusiasts
is building this morning in new mexico
that's where
in a little more than 24 hours
billionaire richard branson's company
virgin galactic will send him and three
other employees to the edge of space
it's another milestone in the emerging
commercial market of sub-orbital flight
mark strossman got the premier
assignment and he is near truth
or consequences about 150 miles south of
albuquerque
where the flight will take off mark good
morning
hey michelle good morning truth or
consequence is a great name for a
city isn't it it's pretty close to here
where we are is spaceport america this
is where the flight's going to happen
behind me you can see a replica
of the virgin galactic space plane
people here
both excited and nervous there is a lot
riding on this moment
i'll be evaluating the customer space
flight experience
billionaire richard branson has weekend
plans he's going joyriding into space
on sunday morning you know government's
not that interested in making
your eye astronauts or people watching
this program
and so after a while we thought screw it
let's do it
virgin galactic's space approach
involves a plane within a plane
its mothership vms eve is a twin
fuselage aircraft with two pilots
in its middle the space plane vss
unity at about 45 000 feet
eve will release unity fire fire
the space plane will shoot straight up
more than 50 miles to the edge of space
its four passengers including branson
will experience
several minutes of weightlessness
welcome to the club astronauts
unity's pilots then will glide everyone
back to earth
at spaceport america virgin galactic's
hub
so this is the beginning of the public
getting to go to space
scott mclaughlin runs this facility he
knows the future of space tourism
will also ride on sunday's flight we
hope for the best but
we've done everything we can to prepare
for a bad day
and we want virgin galactic to succeed
blue origin
billionaire jeff bezos's space company
will launch
their boss to space on july 20th branson
will beat him there
by nine days do you see blue origin as a
competitor
do you and bezos bow up when you see
each other
um we're both doing something in the
same space but very differently
we may be competing but we're not really
competing for passengers because
there'll be plenty of
people who want to be astronauts who'll
sign up to both of us
if all goes well branson hopes to start
regular flights for tourists sometime
next year he has a closed uh
waiting list of folks eager to fly about
600 people
they've all paid big money up front for
their chance to go up
and look back on earth from space i know
marcus
you're dying to go i know perhaps two of
my co-anchors here would love to go this
is really
everyone else's chance their shot
to get into space right you have half a
million dollars
except for that can the cost come down a
little bit i think there's a lot of
excitement
for this from a lot of people but
there's also some nerves oh yeah
and i think people are just want to see
things go
well right we have not gotten rid of
that idea of exploring of wanting to go
into
the next frontier yeah i've been barred
from going
everybody she's not going mark don't
worry